Michael Bloomberg is reportedly preparing
to enter the presidential race.
Michael Bloomberg is a 77 year old billionaire
originally from right down the road from our
studio in Brighton, Massachusetts.
He's been the mayor of New York city.
He has switched from Republican to Democrat
in the last year or two.
He's been an independent at different points
in his life.
I believe he's always been independent minded
to the extent that that means anything in
the modern political status quo of a relatively
narrow Overton window of what's acceptable
and his idea of running for president is absolutely
terrible.
Now I know that there's a lot of people just
tweeting stuff like we don't need another
billionaire in the race.
Some a sentiment I shared on Twitter and that's
true.
I mean this would make a Michael Bloomberg
the second a billionaire in the democratic
primary along with Tom Stier.
And if you won the primary, the race becomes
73 year old billionaire against 77 year old
billionaire.
Not exactly the wide range of choice that
you would imagine you could get from a country
of 340 million people.
Okay.
That, that's fine.
Um, but I actually don't think, listen, if
I had to have a billionaire as president who
has political experience and is a smart politician,
if you frame it up that way, of course I want
Bloomberg over Donald Trump.
Of course I want Bloomberg over many other
billionaires.
Michael Bloomberg to me is a combination of
a guy who has, uh, made himself very rich
through his business and also as he sees it,
wants to serve to the extent that he believes
that that's what he's doing.
But this is just not who we need in the race
right now.
And I would actually make the case that if
Michael Bloomberg wants to help remove Trump,
there are other way more effective ways he
can do it than simply running for president.
There's a report that Amazon founder, Jeff
Bezos reportedly asked Michael Bloomberg to
run, which really shows us the class based
realities of our society.
You are turbo billionaire Jeff Bezos.
You don't like the way that billionaire president
Donald Trump is running the country.
So your idea is what's replaced them with
a different billionaire.
Michael Bloomberg, one with a different, certainly
level of intelligence and sophistication and
different politics.
It's the epitome actually of the American
class hierarchy.
Now, let's assume for a second that Michael
Bloomberg genuinely just wants to remove Donald
Trump.
He acutely and specifically is considering
getting into this presidential race because
he believes Trump is terrible for the country
rather than running for president, which risks
helping Trump actually by pulling some democratic
support.
Who knows if maybe he'll end up running an
independent campaign or write in or something
and actually ends up helping Donald Trump
get reelected.
There are any number of ways that Michael
Bloomberg could actually help remove Donald
Trump by Fox news or pour money into something
that will fight Fox news instead of his milk
toast.
Bloomberg TV, which is not a blip on the radar.
That would be a genuinely good use of his
reportedly $53 billion.
This has been suggested by a few people.
I saw Jennifer Ruben write an article about
it.
I believe Kellyanne Conway's husband might've
tweeted about this.
If Bloomberg buys Fox news and just shuts
it down or turns it into something else.
That alone could torpedo Donald Trump's reelection
much more so than Bloomberg running for president.
We've actually discussed before, if Nixon
had had Fox news in the 1970s he might've
survived his forced resignation.
There have been other ideas floated around.
Again, Jennifer Rubin has a piece on this.
She says, a Bloomberg could spend billions
on a campaign for automatic voter registration
and voting by mail that would help Donald
Trump be removed.
He could revive the local newspaper industry
singlehandedly all over the country.
Imagine if we had like five more big papers
like the Washington post and New York times
doing investigative work, plus a bunch of
medium and smaller newspapers, keeping politicians
accountable, that would help remove Trump.
Bloomberg could spend a couple of his 53 billion
to support and promote whoever is the democratic
nominee, all of whom are much more likely,
uh, to, to actually win.
Then, uh, Michael Bloomberg is if he enters
the race right now, the only thing that I
admit, I'm sort of tickled by about the possibility
of a Bloomberg presidency or even a PR Bloomberg
candidacy.
There are actually two things.
One is a Jewish candidate, I think it would
just rile up Trump and bring out the antisemitic
ideas that are buried in his mind and in the
minds of the people around him.
Nobody would be able to resist just like if
Bernie were the nominee.
Okay.
That's a small thing.
But the other thing that appeals to me about
Bloomberg running for president and being
the nominee, again, I don't think he should
enter.
He's not someone I would support, but Donald
Trump would be hugely triggered by running
against the guy who is genuinely a super rich
dude.
Much more so than Donald Trump is.
It's not about comparing multibillionaires
to billionaires, but remember Trump ran on
his supposedly business success and being
so rich that he's not breathable, which was
sort of the same thing.
They both relate to money that he's made in
business, but Trump has at most three three
to 4 billion.
If we saw those tax returns, we might realize
it's actually a lot less.
Bloomberg has $53 billion.
Bloomberg is at minimum 14 times richer than
Trump, if not more, and I don't know that
Trump would be able to handle that.
I think it would be very interesting.
Now as far as Bloomberg entering the race,
in one sense it's already going terribly for
him.
According to a new morning consult poll from
yesterday.
Bloomberg is instantly more disliked than
any other democratic candidates so far, but
he also has 4% support in polling despite
the fact that he's not officially in the race
yet, which is more than club a char.
It's more than Booker.
It's more than yang is more than Gabbert.
It's more than Beto Castro, Tom Stier, and
all of those other people that are around
zero.
So Bloomberg actually could end up in some
debates.
If he does run.
Hopefully it'll be like Starbucks founder
Howard Schultz, who thought about it and then
decided against it.
We will see.
Let me know what you think about the possibility
of a Bloomberg candidacy.
I'm on twitter@deephackmanfollowedtheshowaswellatdavidpakmanshow